non-minimalists
i've been simplifying other aspects of
my personal life i really want to be
able to carry this over within my
business practices as a portrait
photographer
something i've always struggled with is
keeping my pricing uncomplicated
while still providing myself with the
opportunity for potential
additional profits that allow me to
sustain a quality of life that i desire
it seems that almost everything you see
or read out there with regards to
marketing
and sales advice these days are all
about the potential
up sale so to do this within this
industry you
generally create different packages
tiers or add-ons
and this is how you make it happen but i
feel that this starts to overwhelm my
clients
and honestly it kind of overwhelms
myself as well
um so the easiest thing for me to do
would be to give people what they want
and in an easy fashion
and with probably 90 percent of clients
wanting digitals
charging a fee for my time artistic
skills
and then the digital seems like the
logical way to go but this
shoot and burn tactic as the photography
industry
levelingly calls it can make it really
hard to sustain a profit
because many of my clients they just
don't understand the value of these
digital files to us as a photographer
it's basically my original piece of art
they are what i invest my most most of
my time on
and once the client receives these files
they have the option for endless usage
and printing rights for their personal
use
so what i would need to charge in order
to allow myself a sustainable quality of
life
i would probably cause some serious
sticker shock to most and
probably lose a lot of clients so i
guess what i'm asking
is do you have any suggestions with how
to simplify this sales process for me
and still allow myself to make a profit
i think ultimately if i were to rephrase
tammy's question here is as a business
or business owner
how do i simplify my pricing
the best way so that i'm making an
income and also i'm adding value to the
people around me and she she talked
about some ways with
upsells and and add-ons we in
in the corporate world back in the cell
phone days ryan we used to call them
bolt-ons like yeah
and in fact ryan and i were in charge of
of measuring every single day
twice a day these 29 metrics that our
stores were performing on and so
we always had something to beat our
employees up with because they could be
doing really well in 28 and
it'd be like how dare you not sell this
product how dare only
20 of your your new accounts have text
messaging on it
right it should be more like 50 percent
shouldn't it be 100
now yeah i guess not yeah back in the
day this is before text messaging well i
think there's something else going on
here with tammy too is she
is as a photographer and especially in
this digital world
it is uh it's very hard to keep
your own artistic creations to yourself
so i think there's a little bit of that
going on um i mean
what i would say when it comes to the
the the intellectual property
if someone if if i went to a
photographer so i'm looking at it from
the customer standpoint if i went to a
photographer
and i asked them to take some portraits
of me which you have done i mean
we use the minimalist right so they take
the picture of me
um i paid them to to have the picture
they send me the digitals those are my
digitals that i i paid the photographer
to create
for me and now if a photographer wants
to use you know my my portrait
in a portfolio or or uh you know just to
display
what she's capable of doing great um or
he but but
you know ultimately that photographer
doesn't own that
the photographer can't sell my face to
mcdonald's and say oh yeah
i got a great picture of a person here
that would look great for this campaign
that you're looking to do
right and and i think maybe there's a
little bit of that going on
am i am i wrong yeah i think so i think
sometimes we're very precious
everything is precious to us well i mean
think about your your old business right
one of the reasons you didn't want to
let it go because i built this and it is
precious to me
well and then when something becomes too
precious that to me is a sign
that i need to maybe not let go but at
least loosen my grip a little bit that's
an interesting point you know it's very
minimalist
to think to think that you should let
that go that that's a sign that you
should let go
whereas you're right one of the hardest
things of letting go with the old
businesses
but what about all those recordings of
my voice as far as i know i kind of have
an
unlimited reserve of the ability to talk
and if you ask my wife she'll confirm
that
right so like what's the big deal those
things happen in the past if you're an
nba player
and you play a game and you're watching
a replay of that game on espn 17 or
whatever are you like that's mine
no you're like that's a thing that
happened and now it's over yeah
yeah and so the uh the word complex the
root of that word is
complex and it means to bind two things
together
and so right now she's what she's saying
is a lot of photographers they complect
their businesses they make it more
complex by
having a complex pricing structure and
if you want to
the opposite of complex is singular
simplify
and if you just want i mean to me as a
customer
let's talk about this right so so
actually the people we started our
coffee shop with
uh joshua and sarah weaver are two
really talented photographers that's how
we met them
they did the photos for all of our books
and um
and so when we brought them out to do
some photos
they were talking about opening this
coffee shop they were both working for
like these
these digital uh marketing agencies and
they're like uh we're kind of burnt out
on this we want to do our own thing
showcase our own creativity in a
different way and uh we built a really
great relationship with them because
they came out to take some photos of us
for
for some books and we we quickly became
friends
so you'll also learn that whatever
you're doing might lead to something
else when you're when you're
building these relationships with
clients they'll lead to referrals and
everything else but we went to them and
they came to us with
a price here is your price if you want
some photos you can use them for
whatever you want for books
etc and and we got to say yes or no to
that price
and they felt like they were getting
what they deserved i mean
they may have felt like their their
photogra their photography was worth
millions of dollars i don't know
but the market dictated here's the price
it's really
we're really great photographers we're
gonna come out and we're gonna do
this for two days here's what we're
going to charge you yeah i think really
what
what you're laying out here josh is that
the photographer is
very aware of what the subject is going
to do with the photos
and there's an agreement worked out
between the two of them and i mean
i've got five things written down here i
mean when it comes specifically to the
pricing model like you can basically
charge
you can do whatever pricing model you
want um a like
if you're adding value to your subjects
and your work is outstanding
like that's really what's important
right yeah like so so it doesn't really
matter like what what you're charging or
what your pricing model looks like
i mean what's with sarah and and josh
specifically
it's like we went to them because we
wanted their creativity because we knew
of their
work and the pricing was kind of i mean
it's important it's something to
consider
but we weren't just shopping price right
so and it's a
if you're just focused on price it's
going to be a race to the bottom
yes you don't want those clients and if
you're advertising yes and if you're
advertising price it's a race to the
bottom
and so i think quite often if you
simplify the pricing structure if you
remove this complexity
i mean one one way that we used to do it
in the corporate world if people do want
choices they don't want unlimited
choices though if there's a reason if
you walk into a
ikea you feel really overwhelmed yeah
and
and so they want you know a good better
best perhaps right which is a great
approach
yeah and so you you can lay out well
here are the three pricing tiers here's
what you get for that or maybe you can
just go to a client and say
here's what i charge here's the and it
includes all of this stuff i'm not gonna
give you any add-ons bolt-ons whatever
here's what i include in my service yeah
and that's that's really
the second point that i wrote down as
long as your clients understand exactly
what your pricing includes again it
doesn't if you do a good better best
uh and and let's say that that is
totally uh you know not the norm in the
photography world
that's okay you can do it differently as
long as the p
your clients the people coming to you
know exactly what you're charging and
what they're getting for what you're
charging
the worst thing she talks about the
bolt-ons and the upsells and stuff
nothing pisses me off more oh i was
gonna say that yeah yeah i mean yeah
yeah no no i mean nothing pisses me off
more when i go to to buy something and
they're like oh
yeah um oh you wanted oh you wanted to
take this home with you well
the taking at home charge i gotta charge
you an extra fifty dollars exactly
i mean that's never a good customer
experience man you're having the
convenience fee when you buy tickets oh
it's right so irritating it's
look at i as a business owner and i have
photos taken all the time
if you're like hey i'm 150 bucks and
another person's like i'm 350.
let's say for some reason the work looks
similar to me
i will still go wait a minute if the 150
photographer is like oh but then i have
to come to you and i charge per mile so
that's going to be 47
and then oh you want to use it
commercially okay so that's an
additional hundred
if i start having to stack the math
together and then the 350
person's like oh you live 20 miles away
not a problem yeah you want the whole
day
that's fine oh okay i gotta bring an
assistant that i i
will pay him 50 bucks so i'll charge you
50 bucks fine
but if i start having to go let me get
the calculator out and i'm going oh it's
kind of this that
i don't want to screw with the person
who's going to save me 50 bucks but then
maybe there's this other thing i'm not
expecting later
i'll just pay for the person who told me
the one price
or the two prices because i just don't
care
enough you don't want clients that are
going to split hairs over 15 bucks
or even 150 bucks if they're gonna pay
you two grand
just charge me the full amount
i i've paid photographers five grand
i've paid photographers 150 bucks
there's a difference in quality but if
we ignore that fine
i still want the guy who's gonna go yeah
you're getting a hundred photos they're
all retouched the end
i don't want someone who's like each
photos 20 bucks what if i want more than
that
just simply there's something to be said
for the client understanding exactly
what they're getting and that is worth
money yeah absolutely i think you can
differentiate yourself not by being the
cheapest i mean that's one way to
differentiate yourself but you're going
to get the cheap clients
too and the the way and maybe it's fine
to do that
up front you can do free portfolio work
up front but that's not where tammy is
at this point
you can build a portfolio and you can
you can go out of your way to do a bunch
of stuff for free to add value to people
which is going to build up your
clientele referrals etc long term
ryan and i the 99 of what we do and 99
of what you do jordan is free
yeah and and in order to do that you
know we make money elsewhere
whether it's selling books or we have
patreon etc
but what we what what the way we
differentiate ourselves isn't by being
cheaper
we we differentiate ourselves by being
better or
simpler and i think that's what tammy
can do here differentiate yourself
not by being cheaper differentiate
yourself
by being better and simpler than your
competition